we learned in the in the imaginary
numbers uh a module a video that
hopefully you've watched that every now
and then
in certain equations you end up with a a
square root of a negative number you
know you end up with square root of
negative 1 or square root of negative
nine
and since any real number when you
squared is either zero or positive this
this was undefined for us and then in
order to make it defined in in that
video people came up with this thing
called i and you could call that the
imaginary unit or you know just the
number i and and you define i as saying
well
if i squared we'll just make a
definition this thing called i
when you square it it equals negative 1.
and then that simplifies this the idea
of taking a negative square root because
then you could say oh well the square
root of negative
9 is the same thing as i
times the square root of 9 which equals
3i and how can we say that well what
happens when you when you square this
thing so what's 3i squared
i
squared is equal to
3 squared times i squared this is just
exponent properties
and that equals 9 times negative 1 which
equals negative 9. so 3i
squared is equal to negative 9 and then
if we are
kind of extending the definition of
square roots to negative numbers then we
can go the other way around and we could
say 3i
is equal to the square root of negative
9.
and 3i we can call an imaginary number
and you know it's the word is imaginary
but it's as real as anything i mean to
some degree do negative numbers even
exist they're they're just kind of a
a way of us you know when we put this
when we put this sign in front of things
it just tells us something about how it
relates to this magnitude anyway i don't
want to confuse you but imaginary
numbers tend to get a bad rap because
they're called imaginary numbers so some
people
think that you know they exist less than
other things but with that said any
number you know what times this
imaginary unit i is an imaginary number
when you do
the quadratic equation you realize that
sometimes you end up with a number that
has a little bit of both it has a real
part and an imaginary part
so let me give you an example of that
let's say i had the number
plus
i
that number you might say oh maybe i can
simplify but you really can't you can't
add a real number plus an imaginary
number you can almost kind of imagine
them and i don't want to use the word
imagine too much as in different
dimensions
and and so a number that has a real part
like the five and an imaginary part like
the 2i
this is called
a complex number
complex number
and you could if you want you could even
graph a complex number you could let me
see you could
make the vertical axis
vertical axis you could call it the
imaginary axis
imaginary
and you could make the horizontal axis
the real axis
this is a symbol for the set of real
numbers
and 5 plus 2i well it's real part is 5
so 1 plus oh sorry 1 2 3 four five
that's five
and its imaginary part is 2i so you go
along the imaginary axis or the y axis
you could even say
2 and then you would have this number
here
called 5
plus 2i
in future videos i'll actually do
examples where
we'll make more use of imaginarium of of
complex numbers but now that we've
defined what a complex number is let's
see how it how we can operate with it
so what happens when we add two complex
numbers
image clear image
so let's say we have two complex numbers
one is
a plus bi
so the real part is a the complex the
imaginary part is b i
and let's say that i have another
complex number called
c
plus
d i
and in general uh the symbol that people
tend to use you know you always use x
for when you're when you're dealing with
equations right like x could be any
general real number when you're doing an
equation and in complex numbers that
convention is to use
z the letter z
so for example we could call this the
complex number z1 and it could have been
any i mean this choice of z is arbitrary
and we could call this a constant this
is an i right here this could be
z2 so what is the complex number z1 plus
z2
well that equals this
a plus bi
plus
this is z2 right here c plus di
let me switch colors it's getting
monotonous
so when you add two complex numbers all
you do is you add the real parts to each
other and you add the complex parts to
each other so that equals
a plus b
oh sorry no
the real part so it's a and c those are
the real parts so that equals
a plus c
plus and then you add the imaginary
parts b plus d i
so you have b
i's and d i's so when you add them
together you have b plus d i's
b plus d
in the imaginary direction you can
almost imagine
i'm using the word imagine too much so
it's pretty easy you just add the real
and you add the imaginary parts so what
happens if you multiply two two complex
numbers
so and actually let's just go in order
what happens when you subtract what's
the same thing nothing fancy here z1
minus z2
that's just going to be equal to you
subtract the real parts
a minus c and that's the new real part
and then you subtract the imaginary
parts b minus d
i and this will be the new imaginary
part so this will be the new complex
number what happens when i multiply the
two numbers so what is
z1 times
z2
well that equals
a plus bi
times c plus di
and you might have
we essentially can just foil it out i
don't know if you learned foil in eighth
grade algebra 9th grade algebra i don't
like it actually just think of it as the
distributive property twice so what we
could do is we can take the c plus d i
and distribute it on each of these terms
right so this should be equal to
a times
c plus d i
right
plus
b
i
times
c plus d i all right all i did is i took
the c plus d i and i multiplied by this
to get this and i multiply it by this to
get this and then we distribute again we
get a c
plus a
d i this is an ion my eyes aren't
looking good
a
d
i
plus
now what's b
i times c well that's c
b
i
and then we have bi times di
so you get b times d which is bd
and then what's i times i
it's i squared or negative 1 right times
negative 1.
so what does this simplify to
well this simplifies to i'm going to go
back here
so let's see what the real parts are we
have this term a times c that's real so
a c
and then this last term which was b i
times d i because we're multiplying i
times i we get a negative one but it
becomes real again right
so we get negative b d
minus b bd so that's our new real part
so that was this term and that term are
real
and now what's our new imaginary part
well it's going to be these two terms
added together
so it's
i'm running out of space again
a
d
plus
c
b
all of that times i it's a little easier
with real numbers and maybe the next
video i'll use real numbers but but the
important thing to realize is is you
essentially you just
use the distributive property and
realize that you can only add real terms
to each other you can't add a real to a
a
imaginary and you can only add imaginary
terms to each other and just remember
when you have two imaginary numbers
times each other the i's when
multiplied times each other and you get
negative 1.
now the last operation when you divide
complex numbers this gets a little bit
interesting and maybe a little
unintuitive so what happens if i divide
z1
by z2 so once again that equals a plus b
i
divided by
c plus
d i
how do i divide this
well we're going to use
a property that hopefully you learned in
algebra that
if i multiply
i'll do let me do this in this corner
a plus b times a minus b
what does that equal that equals a
squared
minus b squared
and so if i if i multiply a complex
number
let's say in theory i multiply a complex
number c plus d i
times
c minus d i what do i get i get c
squared
minus
d i squared
and what's d i squared going to be it's
d squared times negative 1. so it
becomes c squared oh i'm out of time
actually let me con let me continue the
division in the next video because it
can get involved see you soon